thailand was thinking about introducing
a 15 tax on bitcoin transactions but
they just axed that plan that's right
there was such an uproar there was so
much pushback the country of thailand
decided not to move forward with it now
that plan previously was all about
cryptocurrency transactions that would
have earned income on any transaction
around trading or mining that could be
recorded as capital gains on income
taxes and so ultimately now what is
going to happen is the thailand's
revenue department are going to take
those plans to strengthen their
oversight and they're going to
completely get rid of them the financial
authorities in thailand last week
announced plans to regulate the use of
digital assets as a method of payment
but they are not going to implement that
15 tax this is a really important issue
because ultimately what we see is
politicians around the world they
realize how much wealth is being created
how much transaction volume is happening
in this industry and they look at it as
a honey pot oh these people they're not
part of the big banking system they
don't have tons of lobbyists on their
side let's put our little stinky fingers
into that cookie jar let's go and we'll
over tax them we'll over regulate them
we'll use them to fund all of our
wasteful spending but ultimately what is
now happening is that the crypto
industry is getting their stuff together
they're starting to learn how to use
public forums like twitter or reddit
email phone calls and many other
platforms in order to go ahead and
provide pushback if politicians are
going to go ahead and try to implement
egregious taxation or regulatory
oversight they're gonna hear about it
from the community and that community is
growing quickly there's a hundred plus
million people around the world that now
hold bitcoin we see every large
financial institution in the world
getting into the game and so thailand is
a perfect example thailand wanted to
implement a 15 tax on bitcoin
transactions for traders miners but now
they are axing that plan it's doa dead
on arrival why because the community has
a voice the community used that voice
and the community told them we don't
want this and ultimately the government
is here to represent the people we
should live in a society where the
government fears the people not the
people fearing the government and so
that is exactly what we're watching so
the government's listening their ears to
the ground they hear that people don't
want egregious taxation on specific
industries like bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies this is where economic
prosperity is happening this is where
job creation is happening and ultimately
this is where wealth creation is
happening and if you are going to be an
adversary of wealth creation job
creation and economic prosperity your
time in politics is likely numbered and
so good to the people of thailand
good to the regulators and the
government officials in thailand for
listening i tend to think that this is
just one example of what's going to play
out in country after country after
country politicians will get excited to
put forward legislation that drives tons
of additional revenue
and the people will speak out and
ultimately the politicians will realize
they work for the people and the people
if they're not heard we'll just vote
them out